ja und über dieses schockierende video
spreche ich jetzt mit meinem kollegen
jörg völkerling jörg was weiß man über
dieses video woher kommt das überhaupt
das video wurde von drei sächsischen
urlaubern der daily mail in
großbritannien zugespielt es entstand
wie im beitrag zu hören waren 30 märz
2007 also gerade mal sechs wochen bevor
maddie verschwand
die urlauber waren damals im rahmen
eines eine art wettbewerb einer
challenge eines radiosenders in portugal
unterwegs ihre aufgabe war es einen
anhänger mit der aufschrift der trip
deines lebens von portugal nach sachsen
zu transportieren und dafür nur zehn
euro am tag aus zu geben indem sie von
anderen rennfahrern mitgenommen
angehängt werden
und auf diesem weg christian brückner
erfuhr offenbar von dieser challenge
durch einen freund und er war auf dem
weg von praia da luz nach malaga wohne
sie dann am 30 märz aufgenommen hat und
dann auf einer drei stunden fahrt nach
almeria entstand dieses video bei dem
man eben scherzend und lachend und recht
jugendlich sieht inwiefern kann dieses
video denn wichtig bei den ermittlungen
seien zum einen sehen willst zum ersten
mal christian brückner damals 30 die
aussaat zur tatzeit das kann natürlich
für potenzielle zeugen ein umstand sein
der ihnen jetzt einfach näher bringt
wenn sie damals in praia da luz beim
ocean club gesehen haben vielleicht
erinnert sich jetzt eine konkrete zum
anderen sehen wir dass christian
brückner diesen vw transporter schon
viel früher als vom bka angenommen in
seinem besitz hatte das bka ging bisher
von april mai 2007 aus es ging davon aus
dass in diesem transporter auch gelebt
habe und in seinem fahndungsaufrufen
anfang juni war die rede davon dass es
hinweise gebe dass er diesen transporter
auch zum laichen abtransport von mehr
die benutzt habe und all diese fakten
und auch dieses diese jugendliche art
die ja da zeigt zeigt wie leicht es ihm
vielleicht auch war auf menschen
zuzugehen und das könnte jetzt neue
zeugen einfach dazu bringen sich zu
melden
die touristen die dieses video
aufgenommen haben wurden ja bereits 2019
schon von der polizei in sachsen befreit
wie lange wird hier denn offiziell schon
ermittelt ja wir hatten anfang juni
dieses jahres ja auch schon gehört dass
sein mitbewohner in augsburg wo er ein
anderes fahrzeug das für die tatrelevant
ist ein jaguar abgestellt hatte dass er
auch schon im vergangenen jahr vom bka
befragt wurden ist offizin offiziell
laufen seit 2013 sogar schon die
ermittlungen gegen christian brückner
damals gab es auch eine polizeipanne in
niedersachsen ist wurde also ein zu
einem zeugen einer zeugenladung an
christian brückner der damals wieder in
deutschland lebt die geschickt mit der
betreffzeile mittelmeer kennen
vermisstensache so war also damals schon
vorgewarnt und es gab auch es gab auch
zeugenaussagen vom abend des
verschwindens von maddie wonach ein mann
der so aussah wie christian brückner
dort gesehen wurden war das versagte
aber christian brückner konnte dann
wieder 2007 im sommer nach deutschland
zurückkehren und was besonders brisant
ist ende mai 2007 findet sich in den
ermittlungsakten auch ein hinweis wonach
jemand ein mädchen auf das die
beschreibung metal and paste aus einem
transporter im vw transporter in
begleitung eines mannes in spanien
gesehen habe das zeigt einfach das passt
einfach auch dazu dass christian
brückner bieber auf dem video sehen sehr
viel gependelt ist auch
zwischenprodukten spanien und
deutschland
jörg völkerling vielen herzlichen dank
für deine einschätzungen